voilà pour ce qui s'est dit durant ces
dernières 24 heures mais à 13 jours du
premier tour de cette élection
présidentielle je crois que l'on peut
d'ores et déjà comparé la manière dont
les différents candidats ont abordé
cette difficile campagne on peut le
faire par exemple aujourd'hui pour le
parti communiste français alors le pc at
il suivi une seule et même ligne de
conduite qu'est ce qui a caractérisé la
campagne de monsieur georges marchais
par rapport à celles des autres
candidats jean-michel mercurol fait le
poids à 13 jours du premier tour 12
octobre 1981 georges marchais devient
candidat du parti communiste à
l'élection présidentielle
georges marchais c'est le candidat qui
est parti le plus tôt dans la course
présidentielle celui qui a tenu le plus
grand nombre de meetings depuis bientôt
six mois celui enfin qui donne
l'impression d'avoir abordé les thèmes
les plus diversifiées au cours de sa
campagne aux grands meetings nationaux
choisi par certains candidats les
communistes ont préféré s'adresser à la
france profonde au travers de thèmes
qu'ils jugent populaire
d'abord les immigrés le pcf dénonce les
ghettos installés dans les municipalités
de gauche
ensuite la drogue qui devient pour un
temps un cheval de bataille de la
campagne
c'est le chant
le chômage les jeunes le pc montre à la
bastille qu'il est capable de se donner
l'image d'une ombre
candidat anti giscard georges marchais
oriente plutôt ses coûts dans un premier
temps contre françois mitterrand
mais le tournant de la campagne ses
cartes sur table le 23 mars pour georges
marchais il faut battre giscard et
imposer des ministres communistes dans
un gouvernement de gauche
dès le lendemain efforts de propagande
sans précédent et la campagne redémarre
à la base
le thème rien ne changera si georges
marchais ne fait pas un bon score au
premier tour il faut contraindre le
président de gauche à l'union et rien ne
pourra se faire sans les lui
la relance de l'esprit ni terre permet
au parti communiste d'enregistrer en
quelques jours la mobilisation de son
électorat
en tout cas le pc le croit et georges
marchais l'ex p je pense que le message
que j'adresse aux françaises et aux
français passe bien mais prudent le pc
ne dira pas quel score il souhaite
atteindre